[Musique]
e
denis robert bonjour je vous interviewez
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle signature view qui joue
l'année c'est vrai on voudrait avoir vos
réactions par rapport à charlie on a lu
une partie de votre bouquin mohicans
pourquoi vous avez écrit ce livre là
c'est un peu la phrase que je met en
exergue de baldwin qui on écrit des
livres pour pour changer la
perception que les gens du monde et ce
livre là
était assez difficile à une longue
période de maturation pour moi j'y
pensais depuis un moment mais un livre
c'est toujours une rencontre entre une
époque un auteur et est une sorte
d'électricité quoi il faut avoir le il
faut il faut sentir la musique dès le
départ quoi et avec moi quand j arrivais
pas pour des tas de raisons j'y arrivais
pas parce que j'étais plein de deux
sentiments et de d'affection pour pour
surtout pour kavanagh
j'avais un peu de rancoeur à l'égard de
deux personnes qui étaient dans le dans
le livre
est donc il fallait que je trouve un une
méthode très sèche et très factuelle de
raconter cette histoire est donc ça
demande une énergie et et un regard et
une profondeur et je l'avais pas et puis
après les attentats je pense qu'un
déclic a été de voir que ce que je
considère comme étant des usurpateurs
occupé les médias et occuper le terrain
et je me suis dit qu'il fallait que je
que je raconte cette histoire l'histoire
que je connaissais de charlie hebdo
d'hara kiri et cette histoire de la
presse mais au delà d'une histoire de
presse c'est l'histoire d'une marque qui
charlie hebdo est devenu une marque
commerciale et je voulais raconter
sa captation raconter les détournements
et toutes les les coulisses de cette
histoire et en faire un récit des
américains appellent ça du new
journalisme mais en tout cas un récit
écrit et distanciée et faire en sorte
que cette histoire parle à tout le monde
quoi donc pour appeler pour appeler
notre communauté à nos auditeurs qui est
denis robert de niro vert c'est là où
vit seul blower français de la banque
qui a eu énormément de petits aléas avec
des huissiers des procédures votre
intégrité n'est plus à prouver j'ai
envie de vous poser une question qui est
kavanagh et qui sont les usurpateurs
kavanagh sans kavanagh on serait pas là
vous seriez pas là une partie de de tout
ce qu'est la presse libre sur internet
une toux tout ça on le doit à cet homme
c'est à dire que dans les années 60 lui
et son son alter ego son acolyte qui
s'appelle georges bernier dans le dans
le surnom est le nom connu professeur
choron donc à deux ils ont créé la
première est à mes yeux la plus
importante aventures de deux journaux et
de presse libre de ce pays voire de la
planète c'est vrai que la fraîcheur de
la voilà il ya eu il ya très peu
d'équivalents sauf aux états unis
les les expériences de free press ou de
choses comme ça qu'il ya eu dans les
années 60 tout qui a accompagné le
mouvement un peu hippie là on a eu une
presse qui a émergé qui allait à
contre-courant de le dos la presse
américaine installée il y avait deux
mouvements en fait en parallèle qui
étaient les etats-unis et la france mais
la france avait une grande spécificité
qui était cet humour bête et méchant
qu'on invente et kavanagh et choron et
donc ces deux personnes kavanagh et elle
est d'ailleurs dans mon livre il ya une
phrase de ville m qui dit il y avait un
malin et un intelligents seront été le
malin kavanagh et et l'intelligent
kavanagh était celui qui écrivait qui
concevait et seront été été l'ingénieur
de tous à celui qui a ramené l'argent
qu'ils avaient un certain génie pour
l'écriture mais c'est vraiment kavanagh
qui se bagarraient qui avaient les mains
dans le cambouis et et dans l'encré et
qui a inventé ce qui avait inventé ces
journaux et surtout qui s'est battu
contre la censure parce que et il est
ils ont pendant 25 années ils ont eu
trois présidences différentes ça vous
c'est très loin pour vous mais c'est
charles de gaulle georges pompidou et
valéry giscard d'estaing et chaque fois
ils ont eu des problèmes avec la censure
mais c'était pas des petits problèmes
c'est à dire que y risquer la prison on
interdisait l'affichage et la vente des
journaux sous prétexte que ça a tenté à
la jeunesse est donc pour eux ça a été
une bagarre permanente et quand je dis
qu'on leur doit tout c'est à dire que la
liberté qu'on a aujourd'hui on la doit à
ces gens là et on leur doit même plus ce
que moi je fais partie de ces gens
comme je sais pas être garé morin ou
d'autres qui pensent que sans eux il n'y
aurait pas eu mai 68 en france et pas en
tout cas mai 68 aussi
ce qui s'est passé à ce moment là qui
était aussi un mouvement précurseur jeu
de je sais je veux pas parler de ce que
de ce qui s'est passé ensuite quoi mais
ce sont eux qui ont déverrouillé
débloquer la société française et au
delà les ddd journaux en europe en
angleterre en allemagne en italie ont
existé à l'image de ses journaux l'as et
donc moi je raconte de l'intérieur
des années 60 à aujourd'hui
comment ça se passe et quad est d'abord
ce qu'on leur doit il ya toute une
partie du livre sur ce qu'on leur droit
cette bagarre contre la contre la
censure parce que ça se passe et c'est
j'ai retrouvé des travaux d'historiens
etc vous avez dans le journal officiel
trois lignes qui interdisent un journal
et voilà vous n'avez plus le droit de le
sortir
là le premier numéro d'hara-kiri
interdit ce temps 61 et
et
25000 exemplaires qui sont faits et ils
savent plus quoi en faire et donc ils
ont passé presque une année avant que le
numéro suivant ressorte d'abord il
fallait trouver qui censure et racontez
vous raconter qu'elle était la
commission de censure l'entretien avec
la commission sans surréaliste quoi ils
sont face à d'abord un fonctionnaire
glisser à l'intérieur puis après avec un
magistrat qui en fait c'est une censure
morale quoi le type il est le journal et
il compte les beats les les journées
phrase il critique les dessins des
dessins de topor qui aujourd'hui valent
des fortunes en salle des ventes vous
avez un magistrat qui trouvait sa noire
est dégueulasse et qu'il fallait pas
passer ça et donc kavanagh ont fait
plutôt avec beaucoup d'intelligence
et en retenant chiron qui avaient envie
de jouer bourre pif il il
il va convaincre ce magistrat de du fait
que ce sont des bons garçons
corrigée et sait et l'a cependant la
première interdiction ils vont faire
pendant une année d'inhumer en fait en
fait sept numéros sur 10 mois uniquement
à un exemplaire ou à deux ou trois quoi
pour pour ces magistrats pour pour mon
présent je suis pour pouvoir ressortir à
kerry et hara kiri ne va ne va faire que
que grimper en qualité et en notoriété
et à un moment ils vendent 250 mille
exemplaires par mois puisque c'était un
mensuel et puis il y devient
hebdomadaire
après après 68 bon c'est toute une
aventure de presse et donc on leur doit
beaucoup qui a usurpé cela alors ce qui
ce qui s'est passé c'est que
au début des années 90 ce
n'est un
araki charlie hebdo s'arrête en
1982 et pendant dix années il se passe
rien il ya des petites initiatives en
france comme comme l'idiot international
mais ça rentre sa rencontre pas un grand
public contrairement à charlie hebdo qui
qui qui vendait beaucoup et qui marchait
très bien et puis faute de lecteurs et
puis l'usure du groupe fait que ça
s'arrête un jour et à ce moment là on
qui se passe dix années et en 92 né un
nouveau journal qui s'appelle la grosse
bertha qui étaient en opposition à la
guerre en irak et qui réunit beaucoup de
dessinateurs dont la plupart des anciens
de charlie hebdo et vers la fin kavanagh
et
un type qui s'appelle philippe val
et dans cette équipe là et avec cabu ils
vont avoir ils vont se fâcher avec
l'équipe de la grosse bertha et eelv ont
décidé de ressortir un journal ce qui
est complètement légitime et eux était
sur une ligne plus politique plus
journalistes que la ligne bête et
méchante de original et ils vont donc
sortir un nouveau journal s'il l'avait
appelée tartempion il y aurait aucun
problème il y aurait pas de l'histoire
et pas de livre aujourd'hui simplement
ils vont l'appeler charlie hebdo et si
vous voulez c'est à mon sens c'est la
première usurpation c'est à dire que ont
la grosse bertha vendée on va dire
autour de 15000 exemplaires
l'exacte e mans le même journal la
semaine suivante en enlevant grosse
bertha et en mettant charlie hebdo
savant 180 mille exemplaires sauf que
c'est un peu comme le le canada dry
coincé à la saveur de l'ancien charlie
hebdo mais ça n'est pas charlie hebdo
mais jusque là à la limite pourquoi pas
quoi il ya des détournements de marque
des choses comme ça sauf que sauf que ce
journal va va petit à petit dérivé à mon
sens quoi et dérivés dans quel sens dans
le sens où
l'idéologie de ce fameux philippe val va
petit à petit prendre le pas sur tout le
reste il va faire des éditos favorable à
la guerre en irak qui va être il va
faire passer ses idées il va faire
rentrer ses amis et des gens qui pensent
comme lui dans le dense non ce journal
il va virer les récalcitrants je raconte
plein d'histoires donc dans un journal
qui a l'apparence de la liberté de ce
que c'était des génies les types qui
crée charlie hebdo il y avait de la
créativité y avait de l'innocence il
avait fait un journal qui était
magnifique et ce type c'est un peu comme
un coucou qui rampe dans le nid d'un
autre et il va en faire un instrument
pour lui au fil des ans au début ils
étaient jeudi tout ça s'est fait
progressivement n'y avait pas un plan
préconçu mais si vous voulez moi moi je
je je démarre cette histoire de nos
jours c'est à dire j'essaie de
comprendre les problèmes qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui indépendamment de l'attentât
parce que l'attentât a trouvé le ciel et
le livre est complètement étranger à
l'attentât n'aurait pas ellis y avait
pas eu d'attentât mais je prends
l'équipe aujourd'hui et l'énorme
problème qu'ils ont puisque charlie
devenu une marque planétaire et j'essaie
de comprendre d'où vient l'origine de
ces problèmes est un peu comme en
psychanalyse jeu je pense que c'est tout
le linge sale et toute l'histoire qui
n'a jamais été racontée qu'il faut que
je raconte tous ses secrets qui n'ont
pas été dévoilés sont anglais ces
détournements qui sont en fait le le le
fait de principe de plusieurs personnes
mais principalement deux personnages
philippe val qui est je vous devez le
connaître il est il est le singe ampleur
dans un ancien chansonnier où il voulait
être léo ferré et puis qui c'était son
rêve qui est le fils d'un boucher
charcutier de neuilly et qui
voit là et qui était chansonnier est qui
et qui va se prendre pour un philosophe
quoi ou pour un homme politique qui
était ambitieux un type qui a soif de
pouvoir mais qui qui à mes yeux
c'est sans doute une des 1 des plus
grands usurpateurs que j'ai jamais vu
quoi parce qu'ils en plus il est
intelligent il sait écrire mais mes jeux
je pense démontré dans mon livre à quel
point il est sans foi ni loi quoi et à
quel point ce qui compte pour lui c'est
le sait le sait le pouvoir l'exercice du
pouvoir et c'est le sait il a il a tous
les défauts de ses ambitieux qui arrive
sans grand talent mais grâce à des
réseaux est ce que je lui reproche
indépendamment du détournement de fonds
quels types de réseaux l'argent etc mais
c'est d'avoir détourné le fonds est le
sens profond de ce journal est d'avoir
grimpé comme ça dans la hiérarchie
dans la hiérarchie de ce pays on va dire
en marchant sur la tête et en écrasant
la beauté l'innocence et la créativité
de génie comme raizer kavanagh et
d'autre et en abusant de la faiblesse et
de la vieillesse de cavalaire vous
parliez de réseau est ce que vous pouvez
me décrire ces réseaux ou est-ce que
vous les connaissez
les réseaux
cc
oui je c'est à dire que c'est assez
troublant de voir que des cas une
pétition des cadets des soutiens on
revoit toujours les mêmes personnes la
maison d'édition grasset bernard henri
lévy le journal causeur c'est toute une
bande
de gens comme ça qu'il ya un premier
cercle et puis ensuite il ya tous ceux
qui ont fait allégeance ou à qui ont
rendu des services des renvois
d'ascenseur et c'est quoi hélas
aujourd'hui ils bénéficient de l'aide de
l'appui d'une dune chargée de
communication qui s'appelle anne hommel
qui était la personne qui s'était occupé
de la com de cahuzac de deux
membres au scan d'omar bongo et qui est
une femme assez puissante
également à mes yeux sans foi ni loi et
qui voilà qui fait tout pour protéger
cette bande c'est des gens qui se
cooptent entre eux qui veulent le
pouvoir et qui qui qui qui écrasent tout
sur leur passage et qui ont des entrées
dans toutes les télévisions les journaux
et c'est quoi et donc voilà moi je suis
le spectateur je suis pas comment dire
mon état d'esprit et nini la revanche ni
la colère ni tout ça
je suis quand même assez épaté par par
la force et la puissance de ces gens là
quoi parce que par ailleurs mohicans qui
vis à vis de livres plutôt bien
d'ailleurs c'est à dire il est sorti
avant les attentats a failli sortie à
trois semaines maintenant et grâce à
internet gratuit au bouche à oreille
c'est un bouquin qui rien primé qui
marche donc je suis pas là pour vous
parler un livre vous parliez de
psychanalyse
avec les attentats on a pu voir
un moment très puissant et ce moment de
très puissant a plus générale une
décompensation parce que 7 des
compensations s'est matérialisée au sein
de cette équipe parce qu'il ya eu un
problème avec cet argent qui a afflué
massivement de google jusqu'à 1 le 6
dans cette équipe le moment je suis pas
dans cette équipe
mais
c'est très compliqué évidemment il ya la
tente à la mort de tous ses amis de ses
qu' on ne peut pas se mettre à leur
place c'est une déflagration c'est
comment vivre après avec ça mais il ya
le problème de il faut continuer et moi
je sais gré à des types comme ris ou
d'autres parce qu'il fallait que le
journal continue il fallait pour des
raisons à la fois symbolique politique
et parce que l'arrêté c'était
c'était
s'était donné raison aux tarés qui sont
rentrés avec leur kalachnikov mais donc
j'ai pas de problème de fond j'ai pas de
problème d'ailleurs avec ce avec le
journal on n'est pas obligé de lire un
journal quoi simplement je sais que dans
l'équipe en fait il ya deux il ya deux
courants enfin il ya deux blocs qui
s'opposent ya la direction qui est
représenté par un ancien comptable qui à
30% des parts aujourd'hui qui s'appelle
eric porto et par laurent sourisseau
dont le nom le nom et eris qui est le
patron de ce journal c'est 70% des
départs puisqu'il a repris les parts de
de chardes est en fait vous avez une
rédaction qui perd de plus en plus
d'éléments puisque peloux et patrick
peloux est parti lui faisait partie ils
essaient de virer par tous les moyens
une fille qui s'appelle zineb voilà il
vous avez une équipe qui baissent les
bras parce que la direction ait
complètement sourde malgré la
communication qui est faite aux demandes
et aux requêtes de de cette équipe en
fait cette équipe qui sont unis sont une
quinzaine peut-être une douzaine
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils veulent c'est
créer une société des rédacteurs et
avoir droit à
aa faire le journal qu'ils ont envie de
faire quoi qu'il ya un partage du
pouvoir dans ce journal et vous avez une
une direction qui est représenté par
l'avocat richard malka qui est toujours
en coulisses et paris ces compagnies qui
eux restent arc-boutés dans l'eure dans
leur pré carré qui est on était les
actionnaires on a le pouvoir et on veut
faire le journal qu'on veut et donc il
ya plus de communication entre eux vous
en avait quelques-uns qui soutiennent la
direction et d'autres qui veulent
comment se positionner ministère de la
culture par rapport aux serbes elle me
serre la culture a joué les pompiers
c'est grâce à eux que le journal a pas
explosé quoi parce que parce que tout le
monde il y avait une vraie bagarre à
l'intérieur de ce journal est ce que je
trouve assez troublant c'est que cette
histoire de société des rédacteurs
c'était exactement le même problème
qu'avait l'équipe des anciens ans quand
92 quand il recrée charlie hebdo
ils veulent créer une société des
rédacteurs et et philippe val marie
cabrette qui est la fille qui ont qu'on
retrouve aujourd'hui là bas leur laisse
croire leur laisse entendre que ça va
être possible et ce que je raconte dans
le livre c'est qu'il ya un avocat qui
s'appelle que j'ai retrouvée qui
s'appelle bernard dartevelle qui lui est
sorti des radars que personnel et qui
qui avait comme stagiaire richard malka
quoi et dartevelle et un est un militant
un partisan de cette société des
rédacteurs en groupe pour qu'un journal
soient libres et que les gens s'y
sentent bien dans des journaux on va
dire
normaux entre guillemets une société des
rédacteurs doit avoir une part au
capital peut-être pas la majorité mais
une part au capital et et charlie hebdo
a fait croire pendant deux trois années
qui voulait faire ça et en fait ils ont
réussi à écarter cette société des
rédacteurs à capter le titre de 2 à
kavanagh la captation s'est fait dans
avec des moyens que je décris dans le
livre qui ne sont pas très qui sont
moralement
pas bien quoi enfin ces terres que
kavanagh
était le fondateur le créateur le génie
qui a monté tout ça et il va se
retrouver dans un journal où il n'est
plus rien il est il et il est plus
actionnaire il est pigiste quoi et en
face vous avez philippe val qui se prend
des gros salaires c'est quoi garossos
à la fin il avait gagné quatorze mille
et 13 1900 euros et que sa cavale a
gagné combien et kavanagh il était piste
à 1800 euros mais il avait parce que
quand même c'était tellement évident
nous tient dans votre bouquin il ya
quelque chose qui m'a qui m'a blessé
c'est l'attitude du journal face à
kavala et aux facs savez nous sommes une
chaîne de hackers et je me suis projeté
dans ce vieux bureau
que vous décrivez très bien avec cette
chaise 7 chaises en paille avec kavanagh
qui écrivait encore à la main qu'ils ne
maîtrisaient pas et qui préférait écrire
avec sa plume et ils envoyaient la c
chronique par fax et le fax en 2010 est
tombée en panne et on lui a pas changé
son fils ouais c'est le signe que il
était contrairement parce qu on se
servait de lui comme une comme une
vitrine et une potiche quoi et donc et
donc quand le faxer open on le remplace
pas donc il doit se débrouiller pour
continuer à écrire ses chroniques et lui
continue à les écrire parce qu'il est il
et les graphes oman quoi il écrit tous
les jours mais c'est aussi son
gagne-pain quoi parce que à cause de la
gestion de choron il a pas de retraite
et donc ils et les 1800 balles qui
touchent 2000 belle l'aide et en plus il
a c'est ce que lui a octroyée ce que lui
ont octroyé philippe val et l'avocat
malka 0 point 4 % sur les ventes du
journal qui représente bon an mal an
entre dix et vingt mille 25000 euros les
années au journal vend bien qui complète
sa
il a aussi des droits d'auteur mais les
droits d'auteur enfin voila il a un
train de vie là des enfants etc c'est
pas quelqu'un qui essaie sûreté dans la
pauvreté mais quand on veut on fait le
ratio est le rapport entre entre des
types qui serait ce parce qu'il ya le
problème de l'argent est quand même
important dans cette histoire c'est à
dire que il touche de file ivan je fais
le descriptif dans mon bouquin il touche
il va toucher plus de 2 millions d'euros
entre les loyers la sci qui crée et
c'est charlie hebdo qui qui qui paye les
loyers et puis les l'argent gagné avec
les numéros sur les caricatures etc il
se partage quand même beaucoup d'argent
et à côté vous avez des types comme
kavanagh qui qui qui ont que dalle quoi
et qui se font même volé il se fait même
prendre le titre d'hara kiri alors il ya
tout un procès mais je veux pas rentrer
dans ces détails le livre comment le
livre a été perçu par charlie par
l'équipe de charlie alors moi j'ai des
très bons retours de
trois personnes qui m'ont écrit pour me
de l'intérieur du journal mais mais il
n'y a rien d'officiel parce que c'est un
bouquin qui les gênent la difficulté du
livre c'est un livre il arrive neuf mois
ou dix mois après les attentats
et je pense que avant c'était que
c'était pas possible parce que je
n'étais pas audible parce qu'il ya un
côté sacrilège que de s'attaquer à
charlie hebdo mais moi je m'attaque pas
à charlie hebdo je m'attaque sans doute
aux usurpateurs qui en ont fait ce qu'il
a toujours dit à ce que charlie aurait
pu s'attaquer à charlie non parce que il
ya
d'abord l'actuelle direction c'est
toujours la même équipe qui était
pupille était au tour de philippe val et
on voit bien que philippe balle essayer
de revenir dans ce journal là et que et
qu'il arrête pas de dire dans les
déclarations qui fait que rice et son
successeur here is no 10 ne dit jamais
un mot contre philippe val et ça ça fait
partie de mon incompréhension parce que
dans mon enquête j'ai évidemment essayé
de prendre contact avec ces gens là je
leur ai écrit il ont ils ont refusé de
me parler et ça m'a déçu de la part de
risques parce que je vois pas gt gt
j'avais aucun a priori à son égard quoi
j'avais des vraies questions à lui
posées par exemple par exemple comment
ce fait-il il qui quand il reprend
charlie hebdo avec charb cabu et
evans lui laisse le journal était assez
florissant grâce aux caricatures et tous
ces journées qui a toujours été hyper
bénéficiaires les jours nice ont été
très bien payé et puis là quand il lui
quand va lui vend il ya un trou de 4
presque 500 mille euros de déficit parce
qu'entre temps bas les y compris les
dividentes ils ont vendu l'appartement
et il se retrouve avec un journal où il
ya ou il n'y a pas d'argent quoi et la
gestion était quand même un peu pas
alors il n'ya pas d'illégalité mais on
est toujours à la limite quoi et et
comment pourquoi comment ça c'est fait
et ensuite tous les procès qu'ils ont
fait à kavanagh dont personne n'a jamais
entendu parler je pense à riches avaient
toutes ces questions là lui poser et
iris m'envoyer un mail dans dix ans qui
met paris mettait en doute mon intégrité
et il a refusé de me répondre j'ai
publié une partie de sa lettre dans mon
livre
et s'ils voulaient l'autre l'autre
réaction qui est quand même assez
troublante c'est celle de philippe val
et de richard malka qui ont refusé de me
voir et qui m'ont envoyé des courriers
d'avocat dire que l'avocat malka a pris
une avocate pour me répondre des lettres
dont je publie des extraits aussi des
très longues lettres où il ne répond pas
à mes questions mais il prend un ton un
peu ironique comme ça pour tout ça mais
bon à la limite c'est de bonne guerre
mais ce que je trouve juste que j'ai pas
trouvé du tout de bonne guerre c'est là
c'est le courrier que mon époux avec mon
éditeur bernard barrault on est très
complice depuis 30 ans donc bernard est
très important pour moi fin c'est plus
qu'un éditeur c'est un ami donc ya pas
et on ne peut pas nous séparer lui et
moi donc c'est pour ça aussi j'ai fait
le livre à julia chez julliard parce que
je savais que ça poserait des problèmes
mais julien appartient à une maison mère
qui s'appelle editis qui possède une
trentaine de maisons d'édition et donc
une dizaine de jours après le courrier
recommandé que j'ai envoyée à philippe
val j'ai re la maison d'édition le
service juridique de d'editis a reçu une
lettre de george kiejman qui écrivait au
nom de richard malka et de et de
philippe val en dix ans dans la led led
led disait en substance vous avez un
auteur qui s'appelle denis robert qui
est en train de commettre un livre
profondément diffamatoire on vous
prévient en gros il demande pas
l'interdiction du league mais il laisse
entendre que ils ont intérêt à faire
gaffe parce qu'il va déposer des
plaintes et s'est même type de procédure
bâillon que vous avez subie sur
clearstream et ouais c'était un curieux
remake
mais qui si oui j'y trouvais pas ça très
intelligent parce que contrairement à ce
qu'ils ont imaginée à l'intérieur du
groupe de julliard ça s'est su qu'il y
avait cette lettre et les gens étaient
scandalisés donc il ya eu autour du
livre une sorte de mouvement de
protection quoi et donc alors après si
vous le problème c'est que j'ai eu c'est
que le livre a été lu relu par départ
des avocats ça m'a pas gêné puisque moi
j'ai pas envie d'être diffamatoires j'en
ai assez donné dans la question donc ça
m'a permis d'être encore plus rigoureux
que je l'avais déjà été
différentes war
il ya eu tout un et il ya eu des
pressions qui ont été faites sur un
désaveu un de mes témoins qui est
l'avocat dartevelle qui me parlait le
conseil de l'ordre des avocats de paris
a fait pression sur lui donc ça a été
très compliqué mais ça c'est pas à moi
on parle et c'est plus à lui donc j'ai
le livre a été traitée assez dur et la
veille ou l'avant veille de sa sortie
j'avais j'avais fait état de cette
lettre de kiejman dans dans les pilotes
du livre et on m'a demandé de l'enlever
alors j'aurais pu me braquer et dire
dire non monter sur ses grands chevaux
il ya quelques années j'aurais peut-être
fait ce à quoi parce qu'on avait essayé
de censurer un de mes premiers livres
qui était pendant les affaires les
affaires contre continue et j'étais allé
chez un autre éditeur mais là je me suis
dit c'est pas grave ce qui compte c'est
que le bouquin sorte que ma parole reste
libre et ça n'est pas un service
juridique d'une dune d'une
multinationale qui va me me me faire
peur quoi parce que le il ya des liens
entre services juridiques et l'avocat en
question enfin bon et tout ça si on
rentre dans ce processus là on s'en sort
plus quoi c'est là où on s'auto censurer
tout un moment donné il faut être un peu
intelligent donc le livre est sorti mais
il est sorti
avec toutes ces difficultés la cua et
c'est assez épuisant de d'avoir cette
pression là en permanence j'ai
l'habitude je pense que si ça avait été
un autre que moi et s'il n'y avait pas
eu cette relation avec avec bernard
barrault ce bouquin serait jamais sorti
chez donc jamais personne n'a revu et
non et c est ce que je raconte aurait
aurait été inaudible et et ou en tout
cas c'était très important pour moi de
faire savoir de faire connaître une
autre histoire de charlie et de charlie
hebdo d'autant que la marque devient
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
planétaire donc il était vraiment
important que les gens sachent que quand
dix ans je suis charlie comme tout le
monde l'a dit il y avait il y avait
vraiment une histoire qui était très
différente de celle qu'on raconte est
être charlie ce que je raconte dans le
livre c'est que le jeu suit charlie et
moi je le suis à la manière de godard
parce que godard suis charlie du verbe
suivre et moi je serai jamais une
charlie de ces usurpateurs mais je suis
charlie j'aime l'esprit de charlie hebdo
même si aujourd'hui je trouve que le
journal mais je peux pas leur en faire
grief mais c'est pas un journal qui est
formidablement écrit et dessiné il ya
toujours des choses intéressantes mais
dans le climat dans lequel ils font
c'est difficile surtout si les meilleurs
ce bar quoi donc voila mais le livre ne
porte pas sur ça mais alors et après il
ya eu toutes les difficultés de la
sortie où je me suis retrouvé face au
rouleau compresseur ça je pensais que vu
comment dire la mauvaise image de
philippe val et tout ce qu'il avait fait
comme comme erreurs et comme conneries
france inter je pensais que les médias
mainstream on va dire ne lui déroulera
pas le tapis rouge comme ils le font
dans une méconnaissance et une amnésie
totale de tout ce qu'il a fait quoi tu
as été sur
pattes et a été surpris de ça mais
regarde comment sont traités les
attentes à l'heure actuelle le paf on
invite que lala qui relègue la kyrielle
d'experts classique
était encore surpris parfum nous sur
internet on a pu surpris du tout de
cette menace que c'est oui parce que
gg c'est peut-être ma naïveté lui je
fais et moi j'aime les gens je fais
confiance aux gens et c'est
se donne un exemple qui peut-être
j'étais invité au moment de la sortie de
clearstream et du film de deep de début
2007 au grand journal par maïtena
biraben biraben maitena biraben elle
m'invite avec des trémolos super accueil
ils font ils font un et et quand le
livre sort
donc si on s y sont nés huit mois plus
tard quoi je le grand journal murray
invite
en me demandant une exclusivité enfin il
passe par mon éditeur et donc c'était
normal monsieur à ce moment là j'étais
invité dans d'autres émissions le livre
devait sortir et donc
évidemment on accepte l'invitation ce
que un livre il faut qu'on en parle quoi
et de trois jours avant d'aller à cette
invitation parce qu'on était invitée
ailleurs et qui avait cette exclusivité
on essaie de savoir
quand enfin et là on apprend que je suis
plus invités dont il pense à comment je
la prends part par mon attachée de
presse qui sur mon insistance à
téléphoner à canal parce que le jeu
peut-être chu naïf mais je sais que
cette fameuse anne hommel dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure qui est une
directrice de communication etc est
aussi très proche de bolloré qui prouve
qu'ils et elles et l'attaché de presse
où la directrice de communication de
charlie hebdo mais aussi de maïtena
biraben mais ma naïveté je me dis cette
maitena biraben et là quand même tu vois
je les rencontre elle a quand même un
peu de de libre arbitre et lé kapab où
il ya une rédaction chef ils ont quand
même un minimum d'autonomie dans ce truc
et vu la manière dont elle s'est fait
enfler par philippe val six mois plus
tôt quand il a sorti ce bouquin merdique
qui s'appelle malaise dans la culture il
lui a menti enfin steria j'en parle dans
mon livre je me dis bon elle va quand
même être mais non mais pas du tout
c'est à dire que yvon des invités ils
vont dire et ils ont invité philippe val
tapis rouge etc
parce que c'est cette fameuse directrice
de la com qui en fait choisi les invités
du grand journal je suis j'en ai rien à
du grand journal d'ailleurs pour
moi quand je vais dans ce genre
d'émission ce qui m'arrive ce qui m'est
arrivé assez souvent j'y vais jamais
avec plaisir j'y vais parce que c'est
mon travail parce que c'est important de
parler des livres mais j'ai aucune
comment dire aucune propension à
m'exhiber danser dans ces médias là je
déteste aller sur les chaînes tout info
on n'a jamais le temps de développer une
pensée une idée etc je suis parfaitement
conscient de la société du spectacle
dans laquelle on est mais j'ai rien
trouvé d'autre quand écrit un bouquin
est blanchi pour l'écrire ça fait trois
ans que tu y penses qui t'habite en
permanence tu as envie de te un maximum
d'un georges alice et a pas d'autres
moyens je suis content de n'être sûr
singer view mais tu vois je veux dire
quand voilà les mais il faut les
utiliser aussi des médias il faut y
aller c'est un format non et là j'ai vu
mais ce qui est vrai pour canal ça s'est
passé pour le figaro pour le point pour
l'express pour i télé pour bfm pour
partout le mec en question valent et
partout et personne ne lui posez aucune
question il fait les les ouvertures du
matin je décris quand même dans mon
livre précisément l'usurpation
j'explique d'une mer très factuelle
comment ça se passe mais aucune question
lui est posée donc ici dieu et j'ai pas
de colère mais j'ai un effarement devant
la la ces mêmes c'est à la fois de la
bêtise de la paresse de 2,2 des
journalistes de ces médias là puisqu'ils
ont des cartes de presse il faut les
appeler comme ça mais mais bon il faut
qu'ils tuent voilà est-ce que tu penses
pas que c'est
une sorte de propagande de propagande
oui au sens où chomsky le dis ça
sans doute mais à un moment il ya une
vraie responsabilité des journalistes
yens je pense à je ne sais pas je thomas
sotto par exemple je les connais pas moi
ces gens là je le vois interview et val
jean lebrun je crois il s'appelle sur
france inter par ace et des types qui
ils ont pas d' excuses qu assez des gens
qui s'ils font ce métier là ils doivent
s'informer avant avant d'inviter des
gens quoi et c'est pas possible de faire
ce qu ils font quoi on a reçus sur sur
ce même canapé les deux journalistes qui
sont fait censurer sur canal+ sur le
reportage sur le crédit mutuel ont ils
nous ont fait remonter des informations
que l'on savait déjà nous sur internet
sur cette autocensure sur le fait que
les journalistes ne faisait plus
correctement leur travail quel quel
bilan toi tu en tires mise à part ton
bouquin sur l'intégrité de la presse à
l'heure actuelle en france
tony tenus par des gros groupes mais oui
je crois pas ou qu'on plonge annoncé
aucun complot je faisais non mais
conjonction m mais pas de notion
d'intérêt parce que ces gens-là d'aidé
que tu les critiques ou dès que tu
aimais un avis défavorable défavorable
ils sont tout de suite lors leur
rhétorique et leurs réponses de taxes de
de conspirationniste et qu' ils sont
libres dans les médias qu'ils occupent
etc c'est ridicule ils sont la liberté
c'était d'abord un choix individuel et
et c'est leur premier censeurs c'est eux
c'est pour ça que moi un jour j'ai
démissionné aussi de libération c'est
pour ça que j'ai le parcours que j'ai
quoi on est on est on est on est jamais
irresponsable on est toujours
responsable de sa vie de ses actes de
ses papiers et quand ils sont honteux
parce que là un certain nombre sont
vraiment honteux il faut le dire quoi et
c'est mais ceci c'est pas pour ça que je
vais comment dire même si parfois je
suis dégoûté arrêter de regarder la
télévision ou que je la regarde quand
même pour me renseigner pas pour
m'informer mais ça me donne des
informations je les ai évidemment sur
internet mais des fois pour voir où ça
en est pour apprendre des trucs j'étais
fasciné par j'ai passé ma nuit aussi
pendant les attentats de regarder enfin
tu voyais avec megatron comment tu as
été fasciné par ce traitement médiatique
exactement pas part
pas par par ce qui était dit et j'ai
trouvé d'ailleurs c'était bizarre parce
que pendant moi j'avais mes filles qui
était et qui étaient dans le quartier
donc
donc il ya eu des moments une une de mes
filles a même été enfermé dans une cave
un moment c'était c'était très chaud et
est donc moi je découvre les attentats
en trois matchs de foot je suis avec mon
fils on regarde le match de foot et je
vois que hollande ce bar et tout est
donc je vais sur sur internet et
j'apprends très tôt par facebook
l'histoire du bataclan parce qu'il ya eu
des machins et tout et je me dis
c'est chaud j'appelle une de mes filles
et elles avaient elles devaient aller
manger au petit cambodge parce que c'est
sa cantine elle est donc elle y était
allé la veille et elles me disent mais
non papa il se passe rien et tout et tu
qu elle pensait que je me moquais d'âge
utilisation s'est faite gaffe enfin et c
est au moment où on se parle il ya des
sirènes et ça commence et tout mais il
est 22h30 22h15 22h30 tu vois et après
je regarde tout ce qui se passe sur
facebook il ya des et je regarde en même
temps itélé bfm jeu ils sont toujours
sur la thèse des huit ou dix morts ils
sont hyper prudent je pense qu'ils ont
ils ont c'était le contrecoup de ce qui
s'est passé en janvier mais ils vont
avoir deux heures de retard sur la
gravité total de 2,2 ce qui est en train
d'arriver quoi et ça j'ai trouvé ça
assez c'est troublant quoi en tout cas
dans le rapport qu'on peut avoir à
l'information ici sont fait un petit peu
taper sur les doigts quand il avait eu
le terroriste dans l'hyper cacher des
fans qui à mon avis ça a dû leur laisser
quelques petites séquelles
mais tu vois par rapport à l'auto
terroristes et aux conversations moi je
jeu j'ai réfléchi à ça et je pense je
pense je je fais confiance à
l'intelligence des spectateurs plus qu'à
l'intelligence des médiateurs et quand
un terroriste appel pour revendiquer
pour pour
dire que c'est bien de but et des gens
enfin qu'il a un discours tellement
délirant
je pense qu'il ya pas de prosélytisme
dans le discours est que et kaki il ça
dépend je me suis pas retrouvé dans
cette situation où il faut tout de suite
transmettre le document mais c'est un
document et j'ai pas à obéir à ce que me
dit ministère l'intérieur ou de la
défense et a pas diffusé je suis un
média libre indépendant je suis
journaliste
un terroriste m'appelle pour revendiquer
un truc c'est mon problème et pas de
faire plaisir aux terroristes ou de
faire plaisir à l'état c'est de
considérer qu'il y avait un écoutant la
formation et ça me dérange pas de la
balance et parce que c'est tellement
délirant mais en fait si je peux même
pas besoin de couper
ils ont balancé les informations au
monde le rsa je suis d'accord évidemment
quand le mec était plan qui sont alors
ça c'est n'importe quoi ça mais c'est
pas le problème c'est parce que je veux
dire évidemment ça il faut faire super
gaffe c'est comme filmées des cadavres
n'ont cessé le parce que là j'ai entendu
j'entendais ruth elkrief dire
qu'il avait eu des appels aussi qu'il ne
devait pas passer etc mais c'est
vraiment parce que le ministère de la
défense ou de l'intérieur leur avait
interdite mais mais je trouve que que
justement ces prédicateurs etc moi j'ai
beaucoup appris sur l'état de la lave la
folie de ces dix la folie d'ailleurs il
faudrait s'interroger sur le terme j'ai
beaucoup appris sur cet arrêt je sais
pas comment les appeler j'ai plus de nom
pour pour les djihadistes en regardant
des reportages sur la rtbf mais qui sont
passés en 2013 en 2012 il ya reportage
que l'on peut retrouver sur youtube ça
s'appelle est gelée mis sur ma page
facebook charia fort belle djoum et avec
l'augmentation des partis politiques un
budget que ça non c'est pas ça c'est on
a des prédicateurs qui se baladent dans
bruxelles dans molenbeek et qui ont un
discours de guerre mais mais est donc le
journaliste c'est un peu traité à la
manière de strip tease un peu comme ça
le journaliste les fait parler quoi les
types tu les vois eyadema père qui
explique à un gamin des le gamin de 3
enfin le il lui parle des armes il dit
que c'est pas bien écouté de la main
toutes les conneries qu'on entend
aujourd'hui ce pas bien écouté la
musique une femme tous et tous ces soi
disant est ce que tu as essayé de te
mettre dans leur tête justement en
écoutant ça tu sais très intéressé là où
moi j'ai un vrai problème par rapport à
ce qui se passe quoi parce que je j'y
pense en permanence évidemment quoi et
comment le problème c'est comment rester
une conscience éveillée dans ce dans
cette multiplication d'informations j'ai
pas grand chose à dire sur le sur le
sujet sinon que
je n'ai gîte jeunes n'agite pas mon
drapeau je ne venais pas été victime
personnellement mais je pense que les
bougies ne servent à rien que la
compassion
ccc ça fait du plaisir aux gens mais moi
ça va quoi et je pense aussi que
est-ce qu'on est en état de guerre je
pense pas qu'on soit dans une guerre
parce que pour être en guerre en état de
guerre il faut avoir un état en face et
je pense pas que l'état islamique soit
un état c'est je sais pas ce que c'est
l'état islamique mais en tout cas je
sais qu'il existe de notre
responsabilité de la responsabilité des
pays occidentaux de la responsabilité
des états unis des russes aussi de la
politique au moyen orient etc jeudi des
évidences quoi mais c'est notre création
cesser ces jolies évidence pour tout le
monde quand tu vois manuel valls qui dit
il nous attaque parce que nous
représentons la liberté d'expression la
france on peut se balader cul nu avec du
ketchup une petite plume
alors que ce on en a interviewé
plusieurs sur notre chaîne youtube puis
on a un réseau aussi dans le
renseignement ce terrain disent
clairement que c'est les répercussions
de nos frappes aériennes pendant 15 ans
et les l'irak l'afghanistan les
mensonges médiatiques qui a créé des
névrosés ségala ses névroses ont été
récupérés par des gourous ces gourous
ont été instrumentalisés financé par
certains services pour déstabiliser
certaines régions et ça donne ça disent
ils le chien s'est retourné contre son
maître je suis avec toute la profondeur
de leurs névroses non mais je suis
d'accord mais après on a un autre
problème c'est un peu comme toutes
proportions gardées avec le front
national à un moment donné quand on
invite le front national on
créée aujourd'hui il a 30 40 % tu es
obligé de le traiter différemment de la
manière dont il traitait avant
aujourd'hui on a un de problèmes
dans ce pays qui est la propagation de
ces types là qu'ils sont capables de
frapper n'importe où et tout le temps
est il des services de renseignement qui
était à la ramasse qui le sont toujours
un petit peu donc le fait de que je me
considère pas qu'on soit en état de
guerre ne me comment dire ne mésestime
pas le problème on est quand même dans
une dans une situation hyper dangereuse
et
j'ai envie d'être protégés avant avant
tout est donc
fait classique c'est est prêt à
sacrifier de thé liberté pour être
protégé alors toi
la loi sur le renseignement si tu veux
en réponse à la question est ce que tu
es prêt sa cruche et et liberté ou non
plus de cette ong pas j'ai pas de
problème
essentiel par rapport à ça sur la loi
sur le renseignement
je veux pas en discuter dans le détail
ce que c'est très compliqué mais je suis
pas opposé s'il veut moi qui suis
journaliste et qui était quand même en
permanence écouter filets par la dst par
les officines tous mes téléphones
étaient écoutés etc je me suis toujours
démerder pour
l'animal téléphone tu vois et donc c'est
pas je vais pas aujourd'hui poussée des
grands cris parce qu'il ya c'est si tu
veux ce maillage et c'est parce que je
suis très conscient d'un autre problème
qui est celui de l'absence totale de
cadre juridique dans le cas de ces de
cette guerre en tout cas contre contre
les djihadistes qui sont en france où
les types qui se retrouvent et
si tu veux le le problème qui existait
et qui existe toujours c'est comment tu
fais ta une information tu sais qu'un
imam ou qu'un type se réunit au fin fond
de l'auvergne ou ou n'importe où dans
une montagne et que des types arrive etc
il faut les écouter il faut les
surveiller il faut les arrêter il faut
voir ce qu'ils font mais y'a pas que tu
vas avoir un juste à prendre il a le
cadre juridique n'est pas possible donc
il ya une nécessité de donner aux
militaires ou de donner aux policiers
des possibilités d écouter ces gens là
de les surveiller et de l'ego les quoi
parce qu'il ya plus que ça aujourd'hui
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il fallait
créer une loi sur le renseignement
qui donne la possibilité à ces menaces
et militaires de faire ça et donc pour
arriver à ces informations là bas il ya
une nécessité d'écouter etc alors après
c'est tout le problème du contrôle de
tout ça mais moi en tant que journaliste
je suis pas là à crier avec
généralement n'en font pas du
journalisme tu vois est ce que tu penses
est ce que tu penses que ceux qui
surveillent les surveillants sont
suffisamment intègre
dans lire un problème de surveillance
des surveillants comme il ya un problème
de cette dynamique ce que tu as
maintenant parce que mais entre deux
mots je choisis le moindre tu connais
cette phrase très connu un peuple qui
est prêt à sacrifier
sa liberté pour plus de sécurité ne
mérite ni l'un ni l'autre
je sais mais ça demande ça demanderait
une réponse plus approfondie parce que
c'est ce que je suis prêt
oui je si tu veux ça me dérange pas
qu'ils aient dans des moments comme ça
qui est d'aider un état d'urgence on est
dans un an 1 mais il faut pas que ça
s'éternise il faut pas que des gens
l'utilisent et puis parce qu'elle
nécessite et de l'enquète je sais pas
enfin je pense que tu as lu la stratégie
du choc de naomi klein non j'ai le
bouquin je n'ai pas lu je vais léger le
relire je vais le lire je connais le
thème je connais ce que je te propose
sur ce sujet là on voit pas c'est un
autre sujet je te ra inviterait une fois
que tu auras lu ce bouquin dont je suis
je te promets en plus gelé chez moi tu
vois messages et des piles de livres
chez moi et il s'aligne lâché en train
de lire
je suis en train de lire nocturne indien
de mécénat voir mais bon
on va on va on va passer
auprès des patients préconisations
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que tu peux
préconisé aux jeunes qui nous écoutent
dans dans l'air qui est en train de ce
temps il ya une augmentation des risques
qui a les signaux faibles qui sont tous
au rouge une caste politique est de plus
en plus soit incompétentes soit qui
réagit dans l'émotion soit d'une façon
symptomatique
un journaliste qui a 16 ans tue les
conseils quoi ça y est il ya 16 ans il
votre journaliste en la question tu me
poses dames mais non non non mais moi
j'ai trouvé g3 j'ai un fils qui vient
d'avoir onze ans j'ai une fille qui a 22
ans et sa soeur qu'il ya 26 ans donc
mon fils j'ai l'impression que ça lui
est passé un peu au-dessus j'essaie d'en
parler avec lui mais ça n'intéresse pas
enfin il n'était pas conscient de et je
pense qu'il est matraqué en permanence
par par ses trucs et que ça crée une
angoisse chez lui et donc on en parle un
peu comme ça et comment tu fais pour
aborder les choses mais moi j'ai écrit
un livre qui s'appelle vue imprenable
sur la folie du monde et c'est le thème
de la c'est l'histoire d'un père et d'un
fils qui se baladent c'est comme un road
movie et
si tu veux en substance que je dis c'est
que les ducs est en tout cas être son
père c'est à la fois le protéger mais
sans le rendre parano et qui continuent
à avoir confiance aux autres mais en
même temps qu'ils soient pas naïfs
qu'ils se fassent pas avoir c'est très
compliqué cette attitude à avoir par
rapport à l'autre c'est à dire que soit
tu deviens fonds national ou
complètement barrée ou d'ailleurs même
au ps il ya déjà des discours comme ça
on t'as une frange méfiance qui
s'installe chez excuse moi là là je
t'écoute en tournoi front national barré
terroristes at il dit nous on a un point
de vue anthropologique sur les
chaussures que on regarde les choses en
face certes les déviances violente que
ce soit l'armée américaine l'armée
française où toute déviance militaire
pour nous on a un regard anthropologique
vas-y contient excusez mon père
racontait non mais la tum tum tum poser
la question de
2,2
discours à avoir par rapport à des gens
plus jeunes quoi d'abord je suis pas un
moraliste j'ai peu de leçon à donner
mais en tout cas je vis au contact par
mes enfants et puis par leurs amis etc
et donc c'est soit la latitude à avoir
cessé mais tous tout ça ne repose que
sur l'information c'est à dire que qu'
il faut que ces personnes quel que soit
leur âge s'informent lisent mais mon
môme devant une certaine réticence à la
lecture comme comme beaucoup donc si il
est beaucoup sur internet il est
beaucoup sur les sites et je crois que
l'information la trouve sur internet
aujourd'hui mais on trouve on trouve on
trouve tout et n'importe quoi il ya les
les thèses comment tu fais tu fais pour
gérer ça quand un gamin de 11 ans qui
est maîtrise de l'ordinateur qui doit de
deux fois supérieure à la sienne ça
c'est rageant car ça va
qui est ce que tu as un filtre parental
sur son ordinateur n'est ce que tu as
pris est ce que tu as appris à surfer à
ce que tu as appris avec lui et je
regarde un peu sur quoi ils servent
parce que je contrôle si je changerais
dessus sur vais sur une île je tombe
dessus quoi j'ai remarqué d'ailleurs
qu'il est dans un certain nombre de jeux
avec sa psp dont et dont d'autres trucs
et qui communique beaucoup
chat interne un dialogue sur des
messageries etc je regarde pas ce qu'il
dit mais en général il va sur des sites
de basket l'idée de sport et de choses
comme ça donc il est pas trop s'ils se
radicalise et on vient quand tu ferais
quoi je pense qu'ici je parlerai avec
lui croyait que le dialogue a que
l'information mais je pense qu'on l'a on
l'a éduqué de telle sorte que
et ouvert à plein de choses qui se
radicalisera pas quoi parce qu'il est
petit peu je peux me permettre de me
mettre dans la tête de ton fils rice le
second ce qui m'autorise juste repris
mon fils il grandit et commencent à
s'intéresser aux bouquins que tu as plus
faire il va regarder ton film enquête
est vrai que son père a été persécuté
pendant des années pour une cause qui
était juste et qu'heureusement que son
père avait un grand coeur une grosse
tête et surtout une bonne tête bollée il
a résisté jusqu'à tout ça c'était david
contre goliath
et un ses amis subi la même chose et il
décide de prendre les armes
tu fais quoi
d'abord il ne demandera pas
l'autorisation il dira rien décidé non
mais je sais je sais pas comment comment
dire je ne sais pas comment tout ça va
évoluer mais si ça
si ça
on est obligé de s'interroger sur la
question des armes aujourd'hui parce que
si ça continue à pourrir un peu comme
c'est en train de se pourrir peut-être
qu'on sera obligé de les prendre les
armes c'est la pire la d re le dernier
recours mais à un moment donné si on
attend on porte atteinte à ma liberté ou
à ma manière de vivre d'être mon
athéisme par exemple on m'oblige et où
je me défendrai quoi fin tu vois et un
moment donné l'aide de la défense ultime
c'est ce à quoi qu'est ce que tu veux je
veux dire
tu penses pas que la défense ultime
c'est faute 2 pour se battre non mais on
n'est pas là mais il a été en train
d'imaginer un scénario noir quoi non
mais je pense quand cela reste sans la
mon prochain film mon prochain
documentaire va être j'ai ça fait un
moment que j'y pense mais je vais
vraiment le faire là c'est être le
portrait d'une d'une femme admirable qui
à 93 ans
qui a résisté pendant la guerre moi ça
donne quoi
je parle s'appelle anne le manoir
et elle et elle a résisté pendant la
guerre et puis après elle a soutenu le
fln en algérie elle est devenue
s'est elle est devenue un d une des
premières elle était secrétaire d'état
du premier gouvernement algérien elle a
un parcours elle a un parcours
incroyable et absolument
inconnu du grand public
et j'ai très envie de faire ce film avec
elle
le sait mais simplement j'ai pas encore
trouvé le temps et le ce film prend
de l'acuité aujourd'hui avec ce qui se
passe quoi parce que la question à se
poser c'est comment résister comment
être résistant comment rester cette
conscience éveillée comment ne pas
croire tout ce qu'on nous dit comment ne
pas s'emballer voilà et mémoire ces
questions là je me les pose quoi mais en
permanence si tu veux je lis beaucoup de
choses là dessus je dis des textes j'ai
des amis qui sont mes mais il perd
remonté contre contre l'islam gd
d'ailleurs j'ai relu un peu le coran ces
derniers ces derniers temps ce que
j'avais jamais fait je trouve que le
coran est hyper violent le coran je
mettais pas mais j'avais m'étais pas
rendu compte de l ua bible j'ai lu la
bible mais la bible et chez lui at on
rapidement maintenant j'ai pas lu la
torah mais rapidement si tu veux cette
lecture m'épuise je préfère lire des
romans et lille mais là la 6e jeu par
rapport à l'interprétation qui est faite
du duduk orange essaie de comprendre et
donc
c'est ni la fille qui disait ça et qui
m'a et j'ai des trucs qui m'ont
je trouve que la manière dont le coran
traite les mécréants c'est quand même un
peu particulier à l'ancien double la
bible n'a l'air d'être un peu plus douce
à cet égard les scènes très différentes
de la part de l'acquisition oui mais
c'est autre chose en tout cas quand tu
vois la manière dont se justifie les
attentats tout tout est justifié par que
par le coran et parlera par l'islam
parce que alors je n'ai pas d'amis
musulmans qui sont hyper modéré enfin
etc mais il ya un vrai problème j'ai des
discussions avec eux mais un autre un
autre problème c'est la manière dont ne
sont pas gérées les mostra qui finance
quoi etc elles sont pas gérées bien sûr
que si elles sont gérées on se fait
acheter de l'intérieur on s'achetait de
l'intérieur ensuite il ya aucune
formation d'imams en france de ce nom et
ensuite les imams salafistes issus de
l'islam la plus rigoriste du sel au sol
c'est un cercle vicieux après c'est sûr
mais mais la responsabilité est pleine
rappelle moi quel est le sponsor du psg
oui non mais je veux ou tu veux revenir
mais on peut aller sur ce terrain là
mais ça reste bien sûr visité d'état
demain oui c'est ça c'est à dire que le
ministre de l'intérieur est aussi
ministre des cultes donc là ça suffit il
faut les fermer les mosquées ces
mosquées la cie les musulmans sont pas
capables de de se gérer entre il ya
cette grande permissivité etc
c'est plus possible de laisser ces
essais quand on les a repérés il faut
les fermer quoi et puis voilà un moment
donné faut arrêter avec les bons
sentiments les folie's pour les avoir
ces sentiments mais il ya une non tu
peux plus accepter
à l'intérieur d'eux dis-moi ce que tu en
penses mais peut-on accepter que des
mecs balancer ses discours horribles sur
les femmes sur la musique sur les
enfants et ce qui est terrible et c'est
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui m'inquiète le
plus c'est la manière parce que là on
est on est sur une génération de
terroristes les moments 20 ans late en
avait un qui avait 15 ans mais il y à
tous les mômes qui sont déjà en brigades
et qui aujourd'hui en quatre cinq six
ans et qui n'ont vécu qu'avec des images
de décapitations et ses méfaits de les
ponts sur la seine ou que les bombes sur
la tête ouais et donc j'ai vu un jeu
sait plus sur quel j'ai vu ça sur
internet mais ça venait d'une chaîne de
télé un môme de trois ans ou quatre ans
qui avait été récupéré par sa famille et
qui pleurait tout le temps parce que son
père l'avait elle était ads chez les
élus avaient fait pouvoir d assistaient
des décapitations et y voyait ça à
longueur de journée et le môme était
drogué par ces images violentes et il
pleurait et dès qu'on lui mettait la
télé avec l'image de décapitation is
calmette mais tu vois ce que ça signifie
si tu en as site en a des milliers s'il
répond à ta question en deux fois la
première pour comprendre la psychologie
des enfants de guerre je te conseille
film de mathieu kassovitz qui traitent
sur ce sujet là et on répondre à ta
question je tends je t'invite à aller
sur internet elle et voir une conférence
de krishnamurti à l'onu en 1985 sur la
paix dans le monde sur qui quel livre
comment ça se passe et peut-être d'avoir
tu penses de krishna merci à mes
krishnamurti mois à lima il m'a fondée
donc j'ai pas en tête cette conférence
mais sa maman reprend demain le livre
que j'ai le plus de faire dans ma vie
mellick ange ses dunes en offrir 25 on
est dimanche c'est de la mort et de la
solitude on est sur un autre sujet mais
krishnamurti est une est une est un type
qui enfin moi j'ai lu ça avec passion
j'ai plein de livres de lui d'ailleurs
si ça fait un moment que j'ai parmi eux
des noms mais je regarderai 7 cette
conférence c'est vrai que ces paroles de
sagesse d'ailleurs dans le bouddhisme et
dans le dans
tu vois c'est une religion qui à part je
trouve qu'il n'ya une plus grande
tolérance
je suis je suis pas boudhiste 1b mais
enfin on n'est pas loin avec krishna
morty donc peut-être là la sagesse elle
est là bas j'ai une dernière question
pour toi
c'est combien
celle d'avant était le père ed
dolman un conseil alors que pour notre
équipe donne nous un conseil pour la
pour notre équipe un conseil comme ça
pourra toujours pour la création de cinq
ans vous
moi je trouve que ce que vous faites et
c'est pour ça que je suis là c'est ccbc
vraiment vous avez une intelligence à
regards en plus ce n'est pas de la même
génération que ceux qui sont avec toi
non mais c'est vraiment de continuer de
messi j'ai même pas de conseil à vous
donner vous êtes vous avez l'air
suffisamment comment dire éveillé pour
mais on a besoin d'eux n'écoutez pas le
regard des autres faites ce que vous
avez en tête et puis est resté une
conscience éveillée quoi et réfléchissez
par vous même en vous informant au
maximum que denis robert merci c'est moi
cinq conseils pour la jeunesse
donc comment blanchir de l'argent sans
se faire choper
alors ça c'est facile ça je peux vous
dire
j'aime bien il ya une phrase d'un juge
que j'ai interviewés qui s'appelle
baltasar garzon qui est un juge espagnol
qui m'avait dit
je comprends pas les braqueurs
aujourd'hui qu'ils prennent tellement de
risques à braquer des banques alors que
c'est si facile d'acheter une banque ça
coûte rien donc mon conseil si vous
voulez blanchir de l'argent vous allez
aujourd'hui peut-être aux îles fidji on
peut acheter des banques pour pas grand
chose
vous créez une banque ensuite vous lui
mettez de l'argent et tout problème de
cette banque c'est de rentrer dans le
circuit et il faut arriver à un endroit
qui s'appelle la chambre de compensation
internationale
c'est tout le thème de mon enquête sur
clearstream et cette banque avec cette
banque vous allez prendre un banquier
dans cette banque vous allez payer comme
vous êtes très riche vous avez beaucoup
d'argent à blanchir il faut que le
banquier swaps soit plutôt beau mec ou
même une nana une banquière avec un bien
sapés etc et puis il faut que cette
banque deal avec une autre banque donc
si vous êtes aux îles fidji vous allez
relais en australie par exemple vous
allez trouver une banque australienne
mais la banque australienne baba savoir
que l'argent est un peu pourri mais
comme vous laisser un petit peu de
commissions elle va elle va accepter
votre deal elle va accepter votre argent
vous avez franchi une première étape
ensuite cette banque il faut qu'elle
s'approche comme je vous disais de la
chambre de compensation une fois qu'elle
sera dedans ça sera très facile votre
argent sera blanchi c'est à dire que et
il faut rentrer dans ce circuit là une
chambre de compensation
c'est un conglomérat on va dire bancaire
où on achète on vend des devises des
actions des obligations ensemble et
c'est une fois que vous rentrez dans ce
circuit là c'est bon vous pouvez
ressortir de l'argent où vous voulez et
vous créer un circuit qui est intraçable
jusqu'à ce que un contrôle se fasse sur
ce type de circuit et un de mes grands
de mes grands combats c'était ça c'était
de faire connaître ces pratiques là et
de faire en sorte que des contrôleurs
puissent contrôler tout ça mais pour
l'instant c'est tranquille vous pouvez y
aller même avec des cylons pas encore
ils ont pas encore contrôlés c'est comme
ça que des gens d'ailleurs se finance
dont
je doive abonnez à médiapart ou charlie
hebdo
il faut vraiment choisir entre les deux
c'est couteau sous la gorge
mediapart
c'est quoi la meilleure école pour
donner un whistleblower
basse et
c'est l'école de la vie quoi c'est con
ce que je vais dire mais
voilà c'est tout c'est un moment donné
si vous êtes cette conscience éveillée
la douleur que vous fait l'injustice est
plus forte que tout est donc faux vous
arrangez pour balancer l'info après faut
être malin quoi c'est pas forcément ceux
se mettre se mettre devant aujourd'hui
il la mésaventure que vit le antoine
deltour qui est qui et le jeune auditeur
qui a balancé les informations de luxe
leaks aujourd'hui les mis en examen au
luxembourg ce qui est quand même
infernal quoi et donc ils sont seul
péché est d'avoir
informé un journaliste il est resté dans
l'ombre et un moment donné il est apparu
et donc il est poursuivi par la société
d'audit et lui ce qu'il a dénoncé ces
commandes des multinationales comme
amazon ikea google etc ne payez pas
d'impôts alors que nous on en paye ce
type il faudrait lui décerner la légion
d'honneur lui donner une bourse à vie et
il faudrait que françois hollande lui
déroule le tapis rouge à l'elysée mémé
tu vois il est il et il est poursuivi
pour avoir dit la vérité donc il ya il
ya encore vraiment dudu du travail quoi
mais je pense qu'il est plus heureux
aujourd'hui malgré tout parce qu'il a
fait ça et parce que c'est un héros quoi
et qui vaut mieux être un héros quinquin
type soumis
cinq auteurs à l'irpp wattam alain jean
guy debord je l'avais si oui alors après
tu peux choisir mais moi je préfère
toujours la littérature c'est à dire que
j'apprends beaucoup plus de choses en
lisant des des romans
que
qu'en lisant
noam chomsky j'ai adoré lire noam
chomsky mais ce qui m'a formé le plus
c'est de cesser de ces gens là m'ont
formé mais moi par exemple le livre qui
m'a le premier livre que j'ai lu
indépendamment de kavanagh de tout quand
j'étais adolescent mais qui m'a donné
envie d'écrire ce que j'écris c'est
truman capote de sang froid qui est le
voilà c'est la première fois que je vous
ce livre va changer ma vie après il ya
tous les livres de richard brautigan
qui est un américain peut-être vous
connaissez pas mais il faut lire un
privé à babylone où il faut lire la
vengeance de la pelouse est derrière lui
derrière derrière derrière lui il ya
john fante théia charles bukowski à tous
ces gens là
après si on est dans l'est dans les
hauteurs plus politique
noam chomsky effectivement mais plus
regarder ces conférences ou ses films
que ces livres parce que c'est pas
quelqu'un qui écrit formidablement c'est
un orateur c'est quelqu'un qui essaie
une puissance intellectuelle mais ces
livres sont assez chiant me semble-t-il
sauf celui que j'ai fait avec lui qui
s'appelle deux heures de lucidité
puisque j'ai je suis un des premiers en
france en tout cas avoir fait un livre
d'entretiens avec noam chomsky donc il
faut lire 2h02 de lucidité
et puis puis voilà quoi qu'est ce que je
peux te conseiller d'autres moi j'ai
relu karl marx récemment je trouve ça je
suis pas communiste mais je suis
marxiste à dire que il ya toujours une
son analyse des classes sociales etc
reste à mes yeux assez vraiment
pertinente quoi et puis
qu'est ce que je lis je lis en ce moment
david foster wallace qui était un
écrivain américain qui s'est suicidée
récemment et qui est
qui a écrit un livre que j'ai commencé
mais il fait mille pages il s'appelle
l'infini comédie et je sais que cet été
vingt très bientôt je vais dire ça voilà
je t'ai donné quelques livres
il faut lire les commentaires sur la
société du spectacle de guy debord plus
que la société du spectacle c'est plus
accessible ces sorties en gros ça coûte
rien il l'a fait en film aussi c'est pas
mal
ouais je suis sorti du chien mais ça
peut dépasser du situationnisme ouais je
sais quoi qui est du journalisme du
journaliste intègre le le kit du
journaliste intègre
qu'estimé dans sa valise
tu cei mais pas grand chose il arrive
avec sa et son couteau quoi c'est
un peu ça le
en général il faut un carnet et un stylo
mais
je reprends truman capote
quand il écrit être quand il écrit de
sang froid samson son livre il a écrit
qu'un seul livre intéressant c'est les
autres son jeu c'est vraiment un livre
important de sang froid parce que on est
dans un fait divers un américain qui est
un l'assassinât d'une famille
et lui retrace le parcours de des
assassins et
et on est vraiment dans la tête des
assassins quoi et truman quand il écrit
ce bouquin il prend pas il prend il a
pris aucune note c'était un mec qui
prenait tout le temps des notes parce
qu'ils étaient journalistes et il a fait
travailler sa mémoire il a mis 12 ans
avec entre le moment où il ya le fait
divers est le moment où le livre sort et
un moment donné quand tu as confiance en
toi
tu te rends compte que c'est ta mémoire
qui fait le tri et est décrit kouame
mais c'est quand et écrivain moi j'ai
une définition assez particulière du
journalisme quand tu es journaliste il
vous dit
aujourd'hui en tout cas au co d'abord il
faut être web journalistes c'est à dire
que tu peux plus être que sur le papier
évidemment et il faut être le plus
précis le plus rigoureux le plus curieux
possible et il faut toujours donner la
parole à ceux que tu mets en cause c'est
la première chose à faire t'es pas là
pour régler des comptes tu es là pour
approcher d'un truc qui s'appelle la
vérité quoi et j'avais un problème avec
ça pendant longtemps parce que j'avais
du mal à en parler parce que la vérité
c'est un concept un peu religieux etc
mais non la vérité c'était une
discussion que j'avais eue avec noam
chomsky d'ailleurs noam chomsky m'avait
dit tu vois cette table et les noirs tu
peux pas me dire que c'est pas une table
et qu'elle est pas noir c'est ça la
vérité c'est aussi con que ce à quoi
donc un moment il faut il faut pas les
lâcher quoi les types veulent pas vous
répondre en général un type qui veut pas
vous répondre c'est un type qui a
quelque chose à cacher et donc le rôle
d'un journal c'est d'aller d'aller
dévoilé c'est pas d'être un délateur
mais généralement quand un type a
quelque chose à cacher sauf si c'est
quelque chose d'intimé évidemment c'est
pas le problème mais généralement c'est
pas voilà il faut aller au bout et puis
à un moment donné il ya le moment de
l'écriture quoi donc un journaliste il
faut qu'ils aient sur son kit à part un
carnet et un stylo un magnéto une caméra
maintenant il faut être un peu shiva
quoi il faut avoir une une grande
pugnacité quoi
plutôt dst ou des gestes
plutôt d'ester ou des gse déjà ccfl
choisir
des séries tu veux dire de
nos jour d'hui le système qui
aujourd'hui où le système d'avant c'est
ça que tu veux tu veux dire non mais
j'ai l'impression que
le système qui a été mis en place qui
veut réunir un peu tout le monde
fonctionne pas très bien quoi
d'un autre côté les renseignements
généraux comme il existait
fonctionnaient pas non plus quoi donc
mais tout le problème reste le contrôle
démocratique donc par l'assemblée
nationale de ses outils de renseignement
et il faut jamais oublier qu'un pouvoir
politique peut changer quoi et donc ces
systèmes policiers que tu mets en place
et que tu crées un jour peuvent être
être aux mains de
de gens qui pensent pas comme toi et qui
peuvent les utiliser contre toi donc
c'est un peu compliqué
contrairement à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure dans l'entretien que je faisais
quoi moi je dans un état
ce qui nous arrive en ce moment en
france il faut absolument un service de
renseignements qu'ils soient
qu'ils sont intelligents et qu'ils
soient très énervé dans le pays pour
essayer de comprendre et de savoir et à
l'extérieur aussi quoi donc ça demande
un ça demande beaucoup de beaucoup
travaillent beaucoup d'expérience et
beaucoup de sang froid
merci beaucoup donné robert b merci à
toi carmen
[Musique]
oh